- I've never talked about
a dick in my life, O.K?
- Penis! Penis! Penis! Penis! Penis!
- BuzzFeed Presents:
Women Talk About Penises
How much do you know about the penis?
- Nothing. I didn't pay
attention in fifth grade.
- I think I know a lot.
- I know a little,
but I'm confident that
it's intuitive enough
to like, really figure it out.
- Sometimes pee comes out of it.
- You think that you're
an expert on everything.
- I am, especially the penis.
- Circumcision: The process
of cutting off the foreskin.
It is done for religious
or medical reasons.
Whether or not it is
necessary for health reasons
continues to be up for debate.
- I'm Jewish, so, this
is my bread-and-butter.
- You cut something off the dick.
- It's for hygiene purposes
as well as to form a covenant with God.
- I just know that the
foreskin is snipped,
- But I wouldn't
- Yeah.
feel confident ever, um --
- This guy's circumcised, right?
- Performing that.
Well --
- Cause, right?
- I'm not seeing a, a hood.
- There's no hood.
- But people are against it now,
because they think that it
takes away the sensitivity.
- That's bull (beeping).
- Wait, how do they do it
without cutting the penis?
- Sperm & semen:
Sperm is a cell that is produced
by the male sexual organ
and that combines with the
female's egg in reproduction.
Semen is the sticky,
whitish liquid containing
the sperm cells as well
as other components.
- [Women in Teal] I didn't
know there was a difference.
- Spermies are the little
guys floating around in semen,
which is the fluid that they live in.
- Sperm is what impregnates a woman.
It's what goes into the egg.
- The sperm is the tadpoles,
and the semen is the gook.
- They're spelled differently.
- Sperm swim in the river of semen.
- Exactly, that's beautiful,
that's beautiful poetry.
- Wet dreams:
Also known as a nocturnal emission,
it is an involuntary ejaculation
of semen during sleep.
- A wet dream is when
a boy is really horny
in his sleep but he don't know it,
and then he wakes up and it's like, boom.
- Teens, uh, they're full of hormones,
they're not having as
much sex as they want,
so they just gotta come in their sleep.
- That would suck to wake up to.
- Yeah, just a whole
bunch of semen everywhere.
- Like, what, do you guys wear diapers
to bed or something?
- What are you gonna do?
You're dreaming about some boobs and ...
- It's like effortless masturbation.
- Girls can't have those.
- Yeah, you can.
- Well, that's ridiculous.
- The prostate:
A gland surrounding
the neck of the bladder
in male mammals that releases a fluid
during ejaculation that
is part of the semen.
- I could not know less about any of this.
- Like if you have an enlarged prostate.
It makes you have to pee.
- You don't know where the prostate is?
- I have no idea where the prostate is.
- That's where most of the men's, like,
pleasure feeling is.
- It's like the clitoris of the man.
- This is how patriarchy hurts men, too.
Because it doesn't allow you to feel
the most pleasure you could feel
by having fingers up your butthole,
because they scare you
away about being gay.
- I know men get cancer from it.
- I just know the exams are uncomfortable.
- If everyone could just, like,
embrace smashing the patriarchy,
men could have really great orgasms
from their buttholes.
Quote me on that.
- Does the prostate have
anything to do with diabetes?
- No!
- Blue balls:
A slang term for the pain
felt in the testicles,
caused by unsatisfied sexual arousal.
- Very aroused male human.
- Balls like, whissh! They
like, expand or whatever.
- And then can't finish his excitement.
- My thing is, do your
balls actually turn blue?
I don't know, cause I'm not gonna look.
- That's real, it's a real discomfort.
- I don't know if it's true.
I feel like it's something a guy made up
to get girls to give hand jobs.
- Why, if he's gonna make something up,
why would he just get a hand job from it?
- Blue balls are so sad.
- Would you rather have a penis?
- It's less maintenance.
- I don't like the idea of having a penis,
cause there's, like,
something between your legs
that's just dangling there.
- I don't need to adjust all the time.
- A penis is so uncontrollable.
- Doing all kinds of tucks and
worrying about these tucks.
Up-tuck, down-tuck, side-tuck.
- I feel like it would be
cool to get a boner, though.
- I wish I could pee everywhere.
- And like, it'd be nice not to like,
have that time of the month.
- That's true.
- I have a dream to write
my name in the snow one day.
- I think you could learn.
- I feel like I'd play
with it all the time.
Like I wouldn't be able to stop.
- What a way to have a secret.
If you have a penis you have
such a secret, you know?
Nobody knows what you're packing.
- [Purpled Haired Women]
Yeah, but nobody knows
what vaginas look like--
- [Woman with bangs] But
it doesn't really matter.
- [Purpled Haired Women]
Yeah, that's true.
- [Woman with bangs] In a room of people
you always have a secret.